dr. who it's such an incredible story in
the annals of television the show's been
on since the 1960s I think well yeah
it's I think it's officially 51 years
old 51 years old and the way they've
done it is the Doctor Who's keep
changing doctor who always has an
assistant and the assistant changes as
well and so now you get to be not
assistant Doctor Who's companion yep uh
and you've been doing it for how many
seasons now this is my third season yeah
and what I love about the show it's
always been true it is so creative and
so and sometimes you'll look at a moment
from Doctor Who and you'll say I don't
understand what the hell is going on
here yeah look it like this scene right
here you and the good doctor seem to be
with Santa Claus what's happening oh
yeah oh yeah we met Santa yeah it's so
hard for a science fiction show to
encounter Santa Claus oh that's a normal
day for me yeah yeah that's just what
happens yeah we time-travel but
bizarrely um Santa there his real name
is actually Nick Frost right so it was
like made in the stars it was made
perfect so so knit for us yeah he gets
to be Santa but why is Santa how does he
fit into a science fiction reality
because um we time-traveled yeah and I
think kind of just hooked up along the
way
yeah sad it's gonna meet soundTouch
really like the writers can do anything
they want anything I think the key to
the show is do not apply logic yes hey
if you don't apply logic you will be
fine right right you're gonna get right
through it no it's nice years ago when I
worked on The Simpsons because it was a
cartoon we could do anything he could do
anything there was nothing that limited
us it was really fun here there's
someone always saying like that's gonna
cost money it's that guy over there hey
thanks for watching please subscribe to
my youtube channel so they will stop
making me shoot these videos please